time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week flu season
is here and its impact is being felt
across the country according to the most
recent numbers from the Centers for
Disease Control every single state
except for Hawaii is reporting
widespread influenza activity this is up
significantly from the same time last
year
here to discuss this flu season and more
is CBS News medical contributor dr.
David agus who joins us from Los Angeles
doc good morning good morning to you
that map is scary yeah why is this flu
season hoarse what's going on
well the dominant flu strain this year
is called h3n2 and whenever that is said
you see the hair stand up on the back of
doctors and public health officials
that's one that's really hard to make a
vaccine to and it changes so even if you
make this vaccine the virus itself can
change as to what we're seeing is you
know already about 60,000 cases 6,000
hospitalizations 20 deaths and children
so far this is a bad flu and it's only
beginning of January this goes through
May David why is this particular strain
more widespread this year well you know
the strains are spread very easily
through droplets somebody coughs and is
talking that droplet can go 2 3 4 feet
and spread it the more droplets you get
the quicker the onset between exposure
and getting the virus and this
particular strain the h3n2 again it's
very hard to make a vaccine against and
when you do the virus changes a lot and
so it's difficult it's been reported
that there's been a shortage of IV
saline bags how is that effective this
landscape well you know with what
happened in Puerto Rico and the horrible
tragedy there that was the dominant
maker of these IV saline bags so when a
patient comes in they've lost a lot of
fluid they need IV fluids believe it or
not we're rationing those bags we also
have very little of the flu medicines
our inventory is low and so supply chain
management critical in management of
things like this which is an epidemic
with the flu it's worried you know I
have to worry literally every day I go
into the clinic do hi I have a
IV fluid and I have to push and pull to
try to get enough bags for my patients
Wow all right our next topic something
near and dear to many of us are smart
phones and other electronic devices
smart phones are still a relatively new
technology and what we know about their
impact on children in particular is
constantly evolving Jana Partners an
investment group and the California
State Teachers Retirement System owned a
combined two billion dollars in Apple
stock they wrote a public letter this
week to the tech giant saying in part we
have reviewed the evidence and we
believe there is a clear need for Apple
to offer parents more choices and tools
to help them ensure that young consumers
are using your products in an optimal
manner Apple responded and at the top of
their statement said Apple has always
looked out for kids and we work hard to
create powerful products that inspire
entertain and educate children while
also helping parents protect them online
David kids are exposed to you know
smartphones computers TV screens it's a
lot of screen time what are the real
concerns here well there been a number
of studies done to really show that the
more a child spends on a screen time the
higher the rate of suicide the higher
the rate of depression and there's a
beautiful study done show that if you
take it away for five days empathy goes
up you actually see personality changes
in the children so what these investors
argue and I love the fact that our vests
are standing up to do the right thing
what they argued is that you know the
most creative company in the world Apple
has to start to make software that we
don't just turn off the cell phone we
actually do it in a way where a parent
can control what a child looks at how
they do it what apps they use what kind
of social media things they're doing
because this is a new generation none of
us actually grew up with these and so we
don't know many of the effects we're
seeing them now but there certainly are
implications that they could have
negative outcomes and our children and
we have to really be aware David how how
specific is that data I mean do we have
information about specific apps and
specific social media programs and their
effect or is it just broadly screen
times and smartphones know you hit it
it's broad data I mean so it's the more
social media sites you're on the more
these effects can be seen in children
but we don't know exactly what and how
many minutes is right how many minutes
is wrong for what age at what maturity
level this is all new and so obviously
we as a medical community need to do
more research Apple as a technology
provider needs to do more research and
together we need to figure out ways to
do this appropriately and safety so
there are good things to these
cellphones and they're bad things so we
need a more collaborative effort David
between between the tech companies
parents and the medical community
exactly and it was in a call to arms
from an investor that brought this our
that's what's interesting and
interesting given the ubiquity of
smartphones and the potential health
side effects it is urgent that that data
collected finally we don't go to
hairstylist for our health but they
could end up saving our lives
maybe the issue is detection of
potentially deadly melanoma which
sometimes shows up on the neck or hidden
on the scalp researchers showed
hairdressers a special training video on
spotting melanoma
after watching the video the number of
hairdressers who said they were very
confident in their ability to point out
possible melanoma lesions doubled and
their knowledge of the illness and its
risks also increased the study was
published by the American Medical
Association that's an interesting way of
working against this David oh no
question about it I mean they're looking
at your scalp I mean most of us don't
see the back of our scalp the side of
our scalp and there's someone there
every few weeks looking at it they're
part of the team and we're all have to
work together to prevent disease and
this is a perfect example where we can
actually make an impact hairdresser most
women will tell you a hairdresser is an
important person in their life but never
more so than now dr. David agus thank
you for that word of advice thank you
for your words of advice doc